global national with donna friesen
[Music]
this is day six of russia's invasion of
ukraine and it has become deadlier the
capital city is being targeted the tv
tower in kiev hit by a missile russia
warns it has targets like this in its
sights and says people nearby should
leave ukrainian officials say at least
five people nearby were killed and
there's a holocaust memorial nearby
where
30 000 jews were massacred by the nazis
in 1941 ukraine's president says it was
also hit
what's the point of saying never again
he asks if the world stays silent now
while many are staying to fight there's
a new urgency for others especially
women and children and the elderly to
leave before it's too late
this was kiev's train station today
and this was ukraine's president
addressing the european parliament
do prove that you were with us he
implores do prove that you will not let
us go do prove that you are indeed
europeans and then life will win over
death
he got a standing ovation
good evening and thanks for joining us
vladimir zelinski says his country is
fighting for survival and the people of
ukraine are fighting back with
everything they have
this is maletto pole a city in the south
east civilians shouting occupiers
risking everything as they try to push
back russian military vehicles and face
down heavily armed russian soldiers
and in ukraine's second largest city
harkev a russian missile hit the central
square this morning killing civilians
people are hiding not knowing what
russia will target next mike armstrong
begins our special coverage tonight and
a warning some of the images are
disturbing
these are the first seconds after an
explosion in harkie the man holding the
camera says over and over it's terrible
at one point he calls the scene putin's
world
this is the heart of ukraine's second
biggest city it's the home to the
regional government offices a place
called freedom square
carrying away a body a man in this group
says
our russian liberators have come
the moment of the explosion was captured
on a surveillance camera a missile of
some kind appears to land just in front
of a building
it was enough to almost take it down
it was probably an airstrike this
soldier says i can't tell for sure
the town's mayor walking in the rubble
put out a message on social media the
fight continues
our army is strong he says we stand our
ground
and for our freedom
the ukrainian president addressed the
european union parliament tuesday part
of his message was about how the attack
on harkeev's freedom square will be
remembered it was enough to bring the
interpreter close to tears believe me
every square
of today no matter what it's called
it's going to be called
as today freedom square
in every city of our country
nobody's going to break us
just all the time bombing we spoke to
this man in harkief he and his
girlfriend are living in an office in a
basement he hadn't gone out for days
until today he helped a group of five
get out of the city trying to go west he
himself isn't leaving because this is
home i don't want to be refuge really i
am not refugee it's kind of my
you know i was born here it's really
it's so strange emotion i didn't want to
be refugee really yeah we started our
trip uh
three days ago now there are others who
have left as it turns out at the last
minute we met this medical student from
lebanon crossing into poland been living
in harkev until he felt it was too
dangerous he says he was right
the place where i'm living was totally
destroyed
even building where i was living
now if bombings like this one are
driving some out they're also pulling
some back
at the same border crossing a man going
in the opposite direction a ukrainian
returning home to fight he tells us for
one reason
anger he says
now there were several places in harkeef
that were hit on this day according to
reports an airplane factory apartment
buildings and a blood donation clinic
nights for the most part have been
quieter but that leaves people wondering
what the morning might bring that
explosion in the harkeef town square
happened first thing in the morning
donna almost at first light
all right mike armstrong in poland
tonight thanks
one of the people in during the night in
harkiev is maria of dieva she spoke to
us from the hallway of her apartment
away from any windows maria what is your
worst fear for your city and for ukraine
for the city my worst fear is that putin
is actually started war against
civilians and they are going to destroy
the city and that for for now that looks
like that because they are for for two
days they are constantly now uh
bombarding the the the residential areas
and people do not have any supplies of
food
medicine or fresh water and they are
also targeting
infrastructure in the city meaning that
there will be probably no heating no
electricity maria we've seen so many
pictures of people in ukraine willing to
take up arms and to fight
what are you thinking about yourself and
your own future it's kind of feeling of
resistance which reminds me what was
going on in europe during the nazi
occupation when people saw everyone
stand up and did what they can because
that was the only way to survive that is
how i feel now if i do not stand up with
others and we do not fight then putin
will destroy ukraine we are fighting
here fiercely because that's our land
and we will stand here because we have
nowhere to go
maria abdieva in harkeev ukraine thank
you
associated press reporter joe fetterman
is in the capital of ukraine joe you've
been there for nearly a week now
does tonight feel different more ominous
absolutely
there's a sense almost that the walls
are closing in on this city just a few
moments ago we heard four loud
explosions it came a couple of hours
after a missile strike on a tv antenna
inside the city that's one of the first
russian attacks on locations in the city
the city itself central key very tense
today not only are the streets empty
which has been the case for several days
but heavy security presence lots of
checkpoints as we try to move around so
there's really a sense of dread and then
in addition to that you have this
military convoy just on the outskirts of
town about 15 miles outside of the city
so really a sense of dread as the
attacks are coming in from all
directions and joe i know russia warned
people in kiev to leave their homes if
they're anywhere near communication and
military facilities but do you have a
sense of what is being hit
yes this missile strike struck an
antenna used by the ukrainian national
uh television station uh and that
antenna serves other tv stations and it
disrupted transmissions so russia
apparently thinks of this uh as a
strategic asset they want to disrupt
communications they probably want to
send a message this is a very symbolic
uh target and they're going to continue
to go after sites like that but it's
important to note that these strikes are
not always accurate and russia has also
been hitting civilian targets right
nearby this antenna for example
ukraine's national holocaust memorial
also struck
president zielenski has said he is
russia's number one target he's still in
kiev he did an interview from there
today what do we know about his
situation his safety tonight we know
very little uh they have been very cagey
very secretive about his movements uh
about troop movements about the
movements of the leaders
but he does manage to come out and make
statements and some of these statements
have been right outside of his offices
so he appears to be in the capitol as
you know he has rejected calls and
offers to leave to safer places so he is
sticking by his people all right joe
fetterman with the associated press in
kiev tonight thanks
u.s intelligence has given this
assessment of the russian invasion it's
estimated the convoy nearing kiev is 64
kilometers long much longer than first
thought u.s officials also believe
russia has sent about 80 percent of the
troops that had amassed at the border
into ukraine and it thinks more than 400
russian missiles have now been fired at
ukrainian targets the u.s also says the
offensive on kiev has stalled and
there's evidence of russian units
surrendering without a fight and running
out of food and fuel
today canada's foreign affairs minister
melanie jolie said canada will petition
the international criminal court to
investigate alleged war crimes and
crimes against humanity committed by the
russian military in ukraine
jackson proskow has the latest on the
international response
draped in the blue and yellow of ukraine
the european parliament heard president
vladimir zelinski's emotional plea for
his country to join the eu
the european union is going to be much
stronger with us he said without you
ukraine is going to be all alone
it's clear the west is on his side the
eu voted overwhelmingly to accept
ukraine's application for membership we
will overcome and we will prevail we are
united and we stay united
while in geneva delegates to the un
human rights commission walked out on
russia's foreign minister leaving him to
address an empty room minister lavrov
was being broadcasted
and giving his version
which is false about what is happening
in ukraine
in a further act of isolation the u.s
now believes russia should lose its seat
at the table with the human rights
commission other nations have suggested
expelling russia from the u.n security
council if president putin succeeds in
his stated goal of toppling ukraine's
democratically elected government
the human rights and humanitarian crises
will only get worse
all the while nato's forces continue
their buildup and training on its
eastern flank as commitments for western
sanctions and military and humanitarian
aid continue to grow
yet solidarity also extends to the firm
limits of western resolve a nato
enforced no-fly zone remains unlikely
plans to provide ukraine with fighter
jets are no longer on the table
both measures seen as too risky for nato
forces tonight the world will be
watching washington closely as president
joe biden delivers his first state of
the union address the speech is likely
to send strong signals about how far the
u.s is willing to go for ukraine in one
unmistakable sign the first lady's guest
of honor is ukraine's ambassador to the
u.s
donna all right jackson in washington
thanks
for some insight into the military
strategy i spoke with retired u.s air
force general hawk carlisle he's in
washington
general from a military and strategic
perspective what do you make of the
russian attacks on targets in kiev
strategically he's trying to
back nato down which i think he got
exactly opposite of what he expected he
wants to move nato away from his borders
he's getting exactly the opposite if you
look at what's happening in the baltic
states and uh on the eastern flank of
nato so
you know that's the part strategically
right now that to me is is um
very concerning at what point do you
think the west moves from helping
ukraine with self-defense by providing
weapons to actually providing defense
yeah that that's a that's a tough call i
mean i if you look at the world leaders
and you look at where nato is
that they really want to get to the
defense of ukraine they really believe
it because they can't allow this to go
un unanswered certainly for
other authoritarian regimes like xi
jinping it would be catastrophic to
allow this to stand
but they're doing everything in their
power to do it by other means and
frankly if you look at where things are
going
um they're having some level of success
by supporting ukrainian supplies and
capability uh they're they're bolstering
the ukrainian defense and again i think
putin mr putin underestimated the
ukraine you know i think the western
powers and the leaders of the western
countries and nato are doing everything
in their power
um to not give him an excuse
by putting nato troops into ukraine or
nato capability actual nato uh fighting
in ukraine but still having the same
impact of of helping defend ukraine all
at the same time diminishing russia
general you know nato carried out
airstrikes during the cost of a war in
1999 they did that without un approval
because it was a humanitarian
intervention at the time to stop the
slaughter of ethnic albanians
what is different in 2022 in ukraine
in this case
you have
an evil uh strategist like mr putin
that has nuclear weapons has chemical
biological weapons
and so it it's it's a different context
and of course then we're 20 years later
uh it's a different world that we live
in in 1999
china was not the power that they are
today there wasn't uh the challenges in
other parts of the world as well so i
you know i think
it's just a different scenario today
with ukraine and i think what
um the leaders in the west and nato are
doing is trying to do everything they
can
short of giving
putin a context to attack
other parts of nato especially the
baltic states which i think would be
moldova in the baltic states i think
could be his next targets
retired u.s air force general hawk
carlisle thanks
there is other news to get to on this
tuesday coming up the two provinces
dropping most public health restrictions
[Music]
public health restrictions continue to
be eased across canada you will no
longer need to show proof of vaccination
in some indoor places in many provinces
saskatchewan and alberta have gone even
further lifting nearly every coveted
restriction heather urex west on
alberta's plans to be open for spring
as of midnight last night alberta has
lifted basically all of the remaining
public health restrictions that were in
place
the sense of deja vu is strong because
alberta has been here before
and of course things then didn't go so
well under the weight of the delta wave
and a summer free of restrictions
alberta's intensive care units nearly
collapsed in late july early august of
2021
we had 90 patients in hospital with
covet and 19 in the icu
now we currently have over approximately
1200 people in hospital in the 60s in
the icu still dr daniel gregson does not
believe the open for spring plan will
result in the same stress though he does
expect hospital numbers will climb if
you look what's going on in denmark
which is one of the countries
our government is allowing for removing
restrictions they are they have gone
their hospital rates per million have
have gone up by about 25 30 percent in
the last two weeks my son is uh we call
it medically complex for families like
the watanabes this is an anxious time a
covet infection for their little boy
could lead to a lengthy hospital stay i
feel defeated i feel completely defeated
i don't know what else we can do i'm
sure we will wear masks for
as long as we
feel comfortable doing it alberta is
also planning to strip municipalities of
the power to put their own public health
rules in place accusing cities of
playing politics i would think that the
premier is going to be more influenced
by politics than municipalities given
that they have just been re-elected or
elected whereas he is facing division
with his own party a leadership review
and an upcoming election there is a lot
at stake
with little patience left for missteps
after two years and five punishing waves
of this pandemic heather urex west
global news calgary
canadian troops in latvia ahead nato's
plan to counter russian aggression
[Music]
ukraine is not a member of nato the
north atlantic treaty organization but
many of its neighbors are and they are
all on edge collective defense is at the
heart of nato an attack on one member
country is considered an attack on all
and as eric sorensen reports canadian
forces in latvia are busy preparing
canadian forces have been leading a nato
mission in latvia for almost five years
but it's more clear than ever how
perilous and important that mission may
be the stakes are magnified in latvia
bordering a country that is not only
waging war but has become more
unpredictable a bunch of assumptions
about how russia and how putin in
particular might behave
over the last couple of years are being
upended basically on every day latvia is
not just russia's neighbor like ukraine
latvia and the baltic countries of
estonia and lithuania were once members
of the soviet union ruled by moscow
about a quarter of the population of
latvia is russian by background and like
ukraine latvia also borders belarus
russia's staunch military partner
what is going to happen to us if ukraine
is surrendered easily says this latvian
resident
we used to be part of the ussr this
woman says she feels the threat it's why
canada is sending more troops to latvia
460 armed forces personnel starting this
month with artillery guns the frigate
hmcs halifax and an aurora surveillance
aircraft are also being sent nato's
mission in the baltics is deterrence
russia respects strength and that's what
nato is trying to demonstrate in their
eastern flank countries like latvia
latvia is convinced that its membership
in nato is what will hold russia at bay
the taser our allies starting from
canadians and ending with other
europeans are with us is a good signal
that
putin don't mess with us it's a
measured response on part of canada to
in terms of the number of troops we're
sending but it's a meaningful one to go
and enhance the deployment that we
already have there while latvia enjoys
nato protection who can be sure of
vladimir putin's next move these days he
has surprised us we have everyone has
said we don't believe he will do this
and he has
so we have to be on guard
and being on guard is the canadian
mission in latvia eric sorensen global
news toronto
next beyond words how ukraine's pleas to
the world are being translated
that is global national for this tuesday
if there is one man who embodies the
fight in ukraine it is the country's
president today vladimir zelinski
addressed the european parliament in
ukrainian his words so stirring even the
translator got choked up we leave you
tonight with part of that speech and a
warning some of the images we're about
to show you are troubling
we are fighting
just for our
land and for our freedom
despite the fact
that all like cities of our country are
now blocked
nobody
is going to enter and intervene with our
freedom and country and believe you me
every square
of today no matter what it's called
it's going to be called
as today freedom square
ten minutes before this the the speech
by president zielenski i saw the
uh
video with these two explosions on the
freedom square in kharkiv
and
you know when he started talking about
this the message was so powerful
and
it's also very personal for me it's a
message
that comes
not from a far away land or faraway city
it's a message coming from the city that
is very very
much
the place close to my heart
[Music]
you